and mitch keller coming off of an outing
where he did not permit a run he'll try
to keep that going here tonight and here
comes the game's first pitch it's swung
on and hit to the right center field gap
this one heading toward the wall it will
touch it covers with speed around first
helmet pops off he'll
pull up in second base and it's a double
to start
as reynolds got that in quickly so the
21 year old rips a double
here on the first pitch of the ball game
bouncing ball backhand newman sets his
feet throws to first and gets him
outstanding work by the pirates to keep
the marlins off the board after the
lead-off double for the marlins tonight
it is cody poteet this is his fifth
career start coming off his first
loss here is key brian hayes
this is hard to center field setting
martay back to the track to the wall
clear the deck with a cannonball the kid
keep ryan hayes
you've got to be kidding me charlie dad
loves it the fans love it
two nothing i mean he just swung
and missed on that slider in the next
pitch he just cranks it out to dead
center field for a two run homer
it's amazing well now you got the
pitcher batting with the bases loaded
all on walks with one out
play at the plate quick shovel got him
there
that's the second out barely gets chism
no nice play by keller you know he got
there quickly but
it wasn't like he was trying to hurry
too fast and you know would overrun it
or
you know can't get a hold of it right
away
he took just enough time to the top of
the order here's jose devers
ground ball fair ball down the right
field line sandy leone will score
polanco digs it out a second run is in
and the marlins have even things up a
couple of doubles tonight for jose
devers
the base is loaded he's going to drive
into a good swing saw back-to-back
breaking pitches so nice adjustment
on the part of devers dwayne underwood
junior is coming on the pitch
walks adam duvall now chaz chisholm jr
got him to chase and so for underwood
three strikeouts
in the inning and so with two outs
polanco and a line drive
base heading to center field to give the
pirates the lead
the one-two pitch that was an offspring
yeah
a team at back team count
so the pirates have the lead back
polanco takes off for second
and is called out for now i don't know
i'll have to take a look at that one he
thinks he's in there
i kind of thought he might be in there
also so
you're gonna challenge he's safe see
that polanco slid in
feet first and he's gonna be five for
five now in the stolen base department
this year
that is the crew chief brian gorman on
one headset
and he'll make the call and he is saved
pirates challenge and the call is
overturned
roach is the best martay and polanco
having some fun
yes kevin roach is tremendous
[Applause]
now don mattingly out and
it looks like an athletic trainer
gene basham out there as well
i'm not sure what this is exactly
of course remember last time that there
there was that uh that
blister or cut on the knuckle but i
don't know if it's in the hand
area or elsewhere
adam simber starting to loosen up in the
limber up limber up yeah the marlins
bullpen
donnie's just begging poteet to be
honest with him if
something doesn't feel right don't
compensate for it
make matters worse and just like that he
takes the ball from him and uh
poteet leaves with an injury of some
sort
second and third nobody out
ball chopped back to the mound played
the plate little flip
and out twice tonight
wait a minute two outs as uh
third base coach trey hillman so two
down
runner goes from first and just fair
out at the plate and
underwood gets out of it as the cheetah
pounces
on that ball and tags out martay frazier
will come to the plate with the bases
loaded how do you do it
to center field that's going to drop in
they'll go station to station another
hit for frasier pirates lead
4-2 73 hits for the major's
top hits leader and an eight-game
hitting streak
pirates add to their lead now up 4-2 and
the bases are still loaded
we've got time to figure it out that in
front of home plate that's a fair ball
and leone stepped on the plate got one
through to first for the second here's
ben gamel in the nine spot
arts leading four to two in the sixth
inning
and big ben rolls one inside
the third base bag and he's not stopping
and dickerson got the throw off
almost got gonzales it's a double
for gamel and the pirates have runners
at second and third
yeah that was a heck of a base hit but i
mean look at that it comes in like a
third base you almost got him
a matter of fact if he catches and gets
attacked he's probably out
now the infield in and here's adam
frazier
and he's done it again adam frazier
singles to left 5-2 pirates
and now key brian hayes and a line drive
past third for key brian hayes
6-2 yeah that wasn't just a seeing-high
ground ball i mean he hit the heck out
of that
and now reynolds and there's a line
drive hard hit toward right
off the clemente wall scores one
reynolds into second with a stand-up
double
as frazier scores from second and it is
now 7-2
five straight hits for the pirates
here's stallings
hit hard and that's past third the
cheetah was hungry
and he gets two and the pirates
now lead it 9-2 one more out to get 0-2
and this should do it and will raise it
again raise the jolly roger
on a jolly good night at pnc park